luke here with the outdoor boys youtube
channel and today i'm gonna make
the ultimate prime rib roast christmas
dinner
and i'm gonna do it over a campfire in a
snowstorm and it's gonna be
so easy check this out guys
let me show you our main course boom a
10 pound prime
rib roast this is a very intimidating
piece of meat to cook for a lot of
people
even in a conventional oven but i'm
going to show you a super easy way to do
it
it's a technique called sous-vide if you
go to a nice steakhouse
lots of the steaks are done sous vide
which is basically
you cook the meat in a hot water bath
and then
you sear it to caramelize the outside
and it gives you the most
perfectly consistent medium to medium
rare
inside but you know what you don't need
any fancy equipment to do sous vide
you can do it with a cooler and i'm
going to show you how
all right first things first we're gonna
season this beef
then i'm gonna show you how to set up
the sous-vide bath all right
got some tine got some rosemary
rock salt honey dijon mustard
and pepper
with all the snow falling on the meat
it's hard to tell whether i put enough
salt on it so you know just do your best
there we go that looks well seasoned now
i'm going to take the honey dijon
just kind of want to pat it on because
you don't want to disrupt the seasonings
could be the hypothermia speaking but
this already smells
amazing now we're going to turn this up
to redneck level 1000 here
we are going to put this whole thing in
a garbage bag
now normally you vacuum seal your meat
before you put it in
the sous-vide bath we got no vacuum
sealer
so we are going to take our cooler here
which is full of not so hot water here
and we're going to submerge the meat and
that's going to squeeze the air out
and we're going to twist this sucker
and i'm going to take a twisty tie i am
going to seal off this bag so water
doesn't get inside and ruin all my
seasoning
little fun fact garbage bags and cling
wrap
don't melt until 200 degrees we're gonna
sous-vide bath at 140. so
we're good now we gotta get out our pot
and start boiling some water now you
don't need potable water to do this
you can pull any old nasty water out of
the lake and use it to cook your meat
because it's not gonna come
in contact with the meat and you're
gonna boil it obviously if you're doing
this with a steak
or a single rib roast it would be a lot
less water needed but i'm doing
a four bone rib roast which serves about
eight to ten people so
i'm gonna need a lot of water
all right we got the water boiling
now the ideal internal temperature for
beef is 121 fahrenheit
and in order to sous-vide that you need
about 10 degrees
warmer so about 130 to 140 degrees
fahrenheit when you first put that
10-pound roast in
the temperature is going to drop
dramatically so you want to start a
little higher than ideal
at about 160. if you're trying to use
this technique on smaller piece of meats
it's the same temperatures you just need
a lot less water
if you have a thermometer great
otherwise use your hand
if you put your hand in and it feels
comfortable you're
about 110 to 100. if you put your hand
in
and it burns immediately you're over
160.
you want to be able to put your whole
hand in like this and hold it for about
the count of one or two
before it hurts and that puts you at
about 150 140.
the bigger and thicker the piece of meat
the longer it needs to sit in the
sous-vide bath so a massive prime rib
roast like that sucker a 10 pounder
six to eight hours is what i expect now
it's not a big deal if you let it sit in
the bath a little bit longer
than it needs but it's a big deal if you
under do it so
you know it's a little forgiving with
sous vide now if i was using personal
stakes
i'd probably only need two hours in the
sous-vide bath
i did some scientific testing last night
and that cheapo little coleman cooler
right there
when you fill it with 140 degree water
it loses 10 degrees of temperature every
two and a half hours now mind you
it's 32 degrees outside right now so in
summer conditions
it's gonna do better so every two and a
half hours
i'm gonna need to dump in some boiling
water to keep that temperature up
all right that's about 160. let's see
how accurate my fingers are here
[Music]
that's 150. all right we'll let that sit
for about two and a half hours we'll
come back and check the temp
even though cooking sous vide sal takes
a lot of hours it doesn't take a lot of
energy or fuel
you just kind of let it sit in the
cooler and go about your business for
the next two and a half hours and then
you boil a pot of water it's
pretty simple so while that beef is
soaking and cooking me and tommy are out
here sledding enjoying the snow
well guys it's been seven and a half
hours and the cooler's maintained its
temperature really well so i've only had
to add
water twice but the weather's gone the
heck in a handbasket i am freezing i am
wet i am muddy and cold and i don't want
to cook in this weather anymore
so i am going to go ahead and just
sous-vide this thing
overnight i can sous vide it for 15
hours instead of
six or eight and it really don't matter
that's the beauty of sous vide it's very
forgiving as long as you don't under do
it
you can do it for 24 hours if you want
so
that's what we're gonna do and we're
gonna pick this up
in the morning
well good morning it's 28 degrees and
that fire
feels very good our prime rib roast has
been soaking in the hot sous-vide bath
for 18 hours now so i'm gonna go top off
some hot water
on the bath get it back up to
temperature and uh
we're gonna start cooking the rest of
our meal the cooler has been holding its
temperature a lot better than i expected
i got it up to 150 degrees last night
before going to bed
it's now about nine hours later and it's
118 degrees still
so that's pretty darn good let me get
the temperature back up to about a 140
range
while i make the rest of our meal
139 good enough these little
battery-powered meat thermometers are
about
15 19 on amazon.com i've got
russet potatoes wrapped in tin foil here
we're just gonna lay these things in the
coal
next i've got a little pot here with
some water in it i got a bag of dried
cranberries or craisins
look at that perfect
start to boil these craisins and they
plump up and then they start
to break down and turn into jelly it's
going to make an awesome cranberry sauce
as the cranberry sauce simmers just keep
stirring it and stirring it
until it turns into this thick
rich cranberry sauce
[Music]
so
[Applause]
i'm getting a little hungry here
wow it takes about an hour hour and a
half for the potato to be
perfectly done through but oh it's so
good
we're just going to have a little snack
here before the main course we got
plenty of potato
we are going to cut up some bacon
we're going to cook up some brussels
sprouts and i'm cutting them so that
they'll cook
more thoroughly in the frying pan and
you cut them long ways
because if you do that they'll stay
together if you cut them short ways
the leaves and stuff fall apart
the brussels sprouts take a while to
cook so you want a lower temperature you
don't want to fuss with them too much
just stick them in the pan
cover them in grease let them sit
bacon fried brussels sprouts
[Applause]
[Music]
once the carrots start to get soft then
we add
the honey
we want them bendy not mushy all right
i just pull these off the heat and let
them sit
all right cooler's at 126. roast has
been in for 21 hours
let's pull it out and see what we got
garbage bag doesn't have any water in it
so it didn't leak
just a big bag of gravy right now it's
beautiful
look at all that gravy right there
we want to flame lick the meat and make
it caramelize on the outside to give it
that beautiful color
and crispy texture on the outside not
cooking the meat
just caramelizing the outside gotta
check my string
make sure i'm not killing it you soak
the string in water before you do this
it'll keep it for burning
she's a beauty oh
prime rib roast baked potato honey
glazed carrots brussels sprouts and
bacon
cranberry sauce yeah that looks pretty
good
moment of truth
oh a little look at that
well this is a little bit closer to a
medium than i would have preferred but
it still got quite a bit of pink in it
so i'm happy with this
but look how consistent the color is if
you bake this in a conventional oven
it'll be really done out here and under
done in here
but because you use a sous-vide bath
it's just consistent
throughout every mouthful will be the
same
and this is pretty darn good
there's christmas dinner right there
doesn't that look
amazing oh the smell is incredible guys
now obviously a lot of you guys aren't
gonna go out and cook a 200
prime rib roast over a campfire but if
you enjoy
a good fried piece of meat over a
campfire seriously consider sous
eating it you know just bring a cooler
boil some water
put the meat in a ziploc bag boom and
you'll have a
perfectly done steak it's pretty amazing
but enough talk i'm gonna eat this thing
oh oh this looks amazing
one nice thing about cooking in cold
weather like this you don't have to let
the meat rest very long
woohoo
oh that is so good
oh that just melts in your mouth well i
think i should wash this down with some
sparkling
raspberry apple juice
oh
well merry christmas everybody and i
hope you enjoyed this video if you want
to see more campfire cooking videos we
got a ton of them
and i'll put links in the description i
did a beef bone broth stew from scratch
i've shown you guys how to make homemade
bread from scratch and bake it over a
campfire
and i've got my favorite like 23
campfire recipes that are just
killer for more practical recipes hope
you enjoy this don't forget to click
subscribe we put out new videos
every saturday morning thanks for
watching guys if you like this video
don't forget to check out the outdoor
boys youtube channel where we have
hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
saturday morning
and hit that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching